um okay guys
let me
let me make sure this is actually
working
first
let's try this again
okay
um
i'm gonna wait until anyone gets on here
all right guys i don't know what is
going on my video camera like will not
turn on right now
um
it's kind of weird no card in the camera
okay well what does that have to do with
it being
a yeah um
but i want to show you guys like a sneak
peek of the pickup video and i need your
feedback on something
um configure video
it's just weird how this
video like isn't working
does anyone know why this wouldn't work
oh my gosh this is driving me crazy
like i was just
it was literally just working on zoom
but i'm assuming you guys can hear me
okay at least let me know in the chat if
you guys can hear me
what i'm going to do today is i'm going
to show you guys like the sneak peek
a little bit that i have um
from the pickup video and i just want
some feedback on it
mostly
because i have um
this audio and i just want to know if it
sounds okay because i constantly get
complaints on my audio like all the gosh
darn time
and
yeah i just want to make sure it sounds
good because i will be devastated if i
get one comment on my audio from this
video
um ideally i'd really like to have my
camera on
a video capture device
but it's just not seeming
to go my way
let's see hold on
the audio is good well i'm gonna show
you the audio from the actual video
gosh okay well
i guess you guys are just gonna see it
on here
um
okay so this is the beginning
so let me know if this sounds okay
this is gonna be kind of choppy because
i still have to edit the intro but i
just wanna i went to a men's
can you guys hear that first of all
pick up boot camp i know what you're
thinking what is a men's pickup boot
camp and why on earth was i there to
answer this question let's start with
what is pickup artistry and where did it
come from when i googled the pickup
artist the definition that came up was a
person that is skilled in striking up
conversations in order to attract a
sexual partner in other words teaching
men how to get laid this became very
much mainstream by the release of the
game in 2005 by neil strauss but even
before then there were entire youtube
and reddit communities dedicated to
understanding women as a female it blows
my mind that there is this much content
out there dedicated to understanding
us like are we that special the second
question why on earth would i as a
female want to attend a pickup boot camp
well you may or may not know that over
the last couple of months i have been
reacting to men's dating and self-help
content this content has given me a
different perspective on men and their
problems but there seems to be some
disagreement on if pickup artistry
you can hear some issues no
oh i'm gonna have to refilm this
oh i'm devastated
why god why like the audio
never works it makes me so mad oh my god
sound is good
it might just be from the broadcaster no
i think there's a buzzing noise but i
was kind of hoping it was too like
quiet and people wouldn't notice it but
it is effective some people say the guys
are creeps some people say that it's
helpful and some people say that it's a
waste of time being the nosy person that
i am i decided to go find out for myself
the first step was finding a pickup
artist that seemed credible i came
across john anthony lifestyle's youtube
channel and i could not deny the man
seem to know how to get hot girls he
lives in a mansion with three brazilian
smoke shows he claims to have slept with
over a thousand women and he has more
evidence of these encounters than anyone
i have seen on the internet the man
seems to know how to get laid the next
step was finding a guide to bring my
initial goal was finding a guy that had
little to no experience with women and
seeing how much this could help
unfortunately most of the guys i know
that are unsuccessful with women like
did not want to improve i guess that's
why they're unsuccessful with women
right
um randomly i met a guy through mutual
friends that randomly i met a guy
through mutual friends that seemed to be
interested oh and i gotta cut that hold
on guys
women right
um random
okay we're gonna oh wait i didn't undo
that
we're gonna get rid of that okay
randomly i met a guy through mutual
friends that seemed to be interested in
going he was very familiar with pickup
and had slept with over a hundred women
while i preferred someone that was less
experienced
if he was willing to be filmed and
recorded it was a win for me
okay the rest of the intro i haven't
edited at all so i have to not show you
that but i'm going to show you
a little sneak peek like the beginning
of the pickup video
i have spent more you don't even
understand how much time i've spent
editing this this is why i've had like
no content the last couple weeks
um so i'm gonna show you the beginning
this morning
okay
with pickup and was interested in coming
he was on the more experienced end with
women but
i figured if he was willing to be on
camera and review his experience that
was a win for me all right guys
i would bust it as hell because i
literally got on a red eye this morning
at the crack of dawn and i'm so tired
so there's a whole
casino right in the lobby
and i could gamble but i'm really like
guys i'm cheap i don't even like
gambling in the room
guys i've been up since 4 30 this
morning i'm so tired i'm about to show
you the room though
okay so this is what a hundred dollars a
night wait 130 gets you in vegas
um so i'm pretty close to the strip and
give me any feedback you guys have on
this video because i want this video to
be really good
and all of your feedback like genuinely
helps me so much like i've spent so much
time on this video that if it flops i'm
gonna be devastated
yeah that's there
like i mean this isn't like a great
hotel
clearly like
literally dirt on the floor um but
i'm in the
vegas hotel
and it turns out like the entire
group of guys is staying here
um
i'm so nervous i'm so nervous about this
i don't know if it's going to be weird
but it's going to be interesting for
sure what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i am
going to be doing something
kind of insane i am attending
a men's pickup conference where they
teach men how to would you say get girls
is the best way to describe it yeah pick
up girls i mean that's why it's called
hiccup
so i'm ryan bergman and yeah we're out
here to check it out give a good review
or a good understanding as to what they
teach so it's kind of interesting
because ryan's familiar with pickup so
he's actually going to be able to give
you guys like a decent review on if this
is guys i regret my makeup so much this
day i'm like looking at this and i don't
i don't know this is the worst makeup
i've ever helpful or not helpful yeah
what are your impressions so far
so
as far as the group of guys that we're
going with
it seems kind of like the typical
culture where
the people that go to these kind of boot
camps they're typically
i almost feel like obsessed is like a
little bit strong but they are
definitely like fixated on
techniques and gimmicks and tricks to
try and
just
pull girls when you were like studying
this stuff were you obsessed with it or
no
to a certain degree yeah so
for me
i actually didn't get my first kiss till
i was 21 i'm 26 now
and
so i
my best friend actually introduced me to
it a little bit
and then i started watching some of the
videos and i started learning some of
the tricks but
the real
value in it is actually learning to
convert
those tricks into something part of your
personality um one of the typical ones
that i would see a lot
is where when you first walk up to a
girl you kind of stick out your hand
and then okay is this interview
interesting there's three people in this
chat let me know yes or no
otherwise i'll cut it
[Music]
oh i can't even show you the rest
because there's people that i promised
that blur out their faces sadly
um but any feedback from that little bit
of the video let me know um because that
would be very helpful
um i need to get my youtube back and
running
i think i just
okay well let me know any other